c'est la revue de presse
[Musique]
avec vous Hélène frad bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline on commence avec
l'émotion immense ici en France après
l'assassinat d'une jeune fille qui
s'appelait Lola une adolescente
retrouvée assassinée vendredi dernier
donc en plein cœur de Paris le calvaire
de cet enfant de 12 ans torturé avant
d'être tué provoque en effet une vague
d'émotion à travers tout le pays une
onde de choc nous dit Le Parisien une
honte de chocs qui s'est transformé en
tempête politique depuis les révélations
sur la principale suspecte une jeune
clandestine algérienne sans papier
cibler par une obligation de quitter le
territoire français d'après Le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France toujours la droite
et le rassemblement national pointe du
doigt la responsabilité du gouvernement
qui accuse lui l'opposition de chercher
à instrumentaliser ce drame le monde
quant à lui évoque un exécutif sur la
défensive face aux rassemblement
national de Marine Le Pen et au
républicains qui n'ont pas à relancer un
débat par ailleurs récurrent en France
la question du retard dans l'expulsion
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
un débat qu'Emmanuel Macron avait
lui-même promis de chlore définitivement
en 2019 lorsqu'il s'était engagé à faire
exécuter 100% des obligations de quitter
le territoire français avant la fin de
son mandat une tentative périlleuse de
flatter l'électorat de la droite extrême
selon le monde qui indique que le
président a reçu hier la famille de
l'adolescente à l'Élysée de leur côté le
rassemblement national et reconquête le
parti d'Éric Zemmour participeront
ensemble à une
manifestation jeudi soir à Paris au nom
je cite de toutes les victimes
le gouvernement Hélène sera un autre
sujet qui s'apprête ça sera l'événement
en politique de la rentrée a déclencher
l'article 49-3 pourra adopter le premier
volet du projet 2023 et d'après les
écoles le recours à cet arme
constitutionnel pour passer en force à
l'Assemblée ne fait pas de doute la
seule question est le temps de savoir
quelles amendements seront acceptés ou
non sachant que le gouvernement a déjà
prévenu qu'il évitera je cite les
amendements qui crament la caisse ou qui
remettent en cause la promesse de WC les
impôts c'est en tout cas ce qui a
indiqué un ministre s'agissant de ce
recours au 49-3 Le Figaro justifie
l'utilisation de cet outil controversé
par le fait que le gouvernement s'est
retrouvé plusieurs fois aux pièces du
mur mis en minorité à l'Assemblée comme
lors du vote sur l'augmentation d'une
taxe sur les super dividendes
proposition qui devrait être écartée par
Elisabeth borne de leur côté la nuque et
le rassemblement national on fait
déposeront une motion de censure sans
espoir de faire tomber le gouvernement
mais pour marquer leur territoire
d'après Le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France qui rappelle que seul une même
motion de censure votée à la fois par la
nuque le RN et les républicains
pourraient faire chuter le gouvernement
mais qui lancera rien en Italie à
présent la formation du futur
gouvernement de Georgia Meloni semblait
en bonne voie Hélène jusqu'à ce
qu''éclate une nouvelle polémique
déclenchée par le Phénix de la vie
politique italienne Sylvio balusconi
alors que les relations entre la
patronne des Fratelli d'Italia et le
patron de Forza Italia son allié
paraissait en effet s'apaiser la
divulgation d'un enregistrement de
Silvio berlisconi faisant l'éloge de
Vladimir Poutine présenté je le cite
comme une personne pacifique et sensée
et se targuant aussi de faire partie du
cercle de ces cinq meilleures amies
risque de tout faire voler en éclat elle
déclenche en tout cas beaucoup de
réactions du côté de la presse italienne
berlus comique ironise il fait au
quotidien qui se demande si le patron de
médiaset n'a pas délibérément cherché à
tout envoyer balader pour se venger de
ne pas avoir obtenu les portefeuilles
qui l'espérait notamment celui de la
justice photos à l'appui Il Manifesto
évoque l'ami retrouvé de Silvio
Berlusconi qui jurait pourtant c'est
grandieux avoir coupé les ponts avec
Vladimir Poutine mais la critique la
plusinglante Pauline on l'a trouvé du
côté de libello le journal conservateur
de Milan qui n'y va pas par quatre
chemins elle s'adresse directement aux
Cavalieri avant que les choses tournent
mal Silvio ferme là
on ne se quitte pas là dessus Hélène
avant de vous dire à tout à l'heure il y
avait deux images que j'avais envie de
partager avec vous la première nous
vient d'Italie justement de Naples plus
précisément ou une douzaine de cercueils
se sont retrouvées en plein air dans le
plus ancien cimetière de la ville après
l'effondrement du caveau où il se
trouvait de Guardian précise que c'est
la deuxième fois cette année qui a un
effondrement touche ce cimetière c'est
la deuxième fois que cet incident donc
survient dans ce cimetière mal entretenu
et la deuxième enfin c'est une vidéo qui
illustre la façon dont les choses se
passent en Chine le pays de la tolérance
zéro pour le coït-19 voici ce qui arrive
à celles et ceux qui sont testées
positifs à leur arrivée dans un aéroport
chinois il se retrouve immédiatement
transportée enfermé dans un véhicule qui
les emmène directement dans les lieux de
quarantaine radical c'est radical
effectivement merci beaucoup